who's talking for a minute
wow i think he talked for like three
minutes straight
um
yeah i don't think jordan peterson is
going to have a problem getting anything
that he wants
i don't think he has a problem
but then equally i don't think michael
dyson would have had a problem or has a
problem now be him being on the stage
do you get what i'm saying i think he's
probably speaking for
people that aren't him
do you know what i mean
he's
speaking for people that aren't him
and
that whole equality of
opportunity opportunity versus a quality
of outcome thing
like
okay i've said this many times like
if you go around the world even in
america
black peop the people that they call
black people occupy the bottom of
most social economic ladders
whether it be in america
i'm talking about the general
possibility
they occupy the bottom of the social
economic ladder so black people will
be the poorest
generally depending on where you go
um they will have
nigerians
no but i'm saying if in nigeria
if another group of people move in
they tend to push black people's down
for instance it happened with this one
of the things that idiot mean was upset
about idiot i mean that was us
nigerians are they they're either equal
or they outpace whites in the u.s no but
i'm saying i'm talking about when you're
in your respective countries oh so for
instance if
ghanaians are in ghana obviously it's a
ghanaian country but if another group of
people are moving into god so the
chinese are moving into ghana right now
and their social economic status
is actually higher than ghanaians
because they get into the meetings they
get seen because they work for i don't
know corporate companies etc etc so i
just i've always said that if black
people generally tend to occupy the
bottom of the social economic ladder and
i know it's something that sounds
controversial now the only thing we are
going to have to do is
determine ourselves
do you know what i mean like if there's
a
if there's a pattern yeah we can't rely
on anybody but ourselves to get
ourselves out of the situation that
we're in and and that's one of the
things that i think
like people have been saying to black
people just get on with it do the job
and you get and i think i tell black
people that too i'm like all right cool
we find ourselves in a position what we
can do about it
what scream cry yeah do you know i mean
march yeah
well i just i think it's like a
mentality i don't know like i think i
think that mentality you're talking
about is just like there's certain
people that it doesn't matter like i
feel like you if i placed you in a state
where you didn't know anybody like you
would figure something out without like
yeah you would figure out how to get a
job and yeah you'd figure it out yeah
yeah and it's just like
because i have yeah because i have i may
have different mentality i've always
said it's like being in a rainforest and
if somebody drops you in a rainforest
it doesn't matter what you think
the snakes are there the frogs are there
the jaguars are there if you stay there
crying for too long
the rainforest will eat you up yeah
right yeah that's a good announcement it
will eat you up yeah if you say okay
cool let me learn the jaguar let me
learn the snake let me learn the
environment you'll survive and i feel
like i'm one of those people i'd be like
you know what forget the crying i need
to survive and i need to get things done
so but a lot of people do they stay
crying in the environment get an equal
voice in this debate back if it is
implied that his participation brings
with it this baggage of white privilege
that doesn't allow him to see clearly
the issues that are before us but that
is to be complicit in the very problem
itself terminologically you're beginning
at a point that's already uh productive
and controversial you're saying how can
he get his equality back who are you
talking about
jordan peterson trending number one on
twitter
jordan peterson with an international
international bestseller
i want him to tweet something out about
me and my book
jordan peterson right this is what i'm
saying to you why the rage bruh
you you're doing well but you're a mean
mad white man and you're gonna get us
right
and well i'm saying that's true like he
knows him
that's true
you don't know he's a mean white man
though like what the hell jordan
peterson is so nice too
and what i'm saying to you empirically
and precisely when you ask the question
about white privilege the fact that you
asking and the way you oh my gosh
what the hell was that
the mean nightmare was not excavating
them
it's like bro just say what you're
saying like why would they like that's
when you know someone has a bad argument
but they use these big words for no
reason it's like for don't just explain
yourself like
i'm like they try to they try to help
smarter than they are you know what i
mean yeah i've had it trust me i've had
it it's about the degree to which we are
willing as a society
number two what's interesting to me
you're talking about not having a
collective identity what do you call a
nation
are you canadian are you canadian by
yourself
are you an
individual see i always say that you
lose you lose the argument when you
start getting personal you do you do
because it means you don't have the fast
things no statistics to wear
see if i if me and you're having a
conversation like yeah but look at your
dress this
is fire
if i go to something then it's just like
yeah i've lost the argument yeah i agree
so the most conservative yeah you're
talking about not having a collective
identity what do you call a nation
are you canadian are you canadian by
yourself
are you an individual or are you part of
a group when america formed its union
it did so in opposition to another group
so the reality is is that those who are
part of group identities and politics
deny the legitimacy and validity of
those groups and the fact that they have
been created
thusly and then have resentment against
others all i'm asking for is the
opportunity the the
the quotation you talk about the
difference between a quality of outcome
and equality of opportunity that's a
staid and retry argument hack need
phrase derived from the halcyon days of
the debate over affirmative action are
you looking for outcomes that can be
determined equally or are you looking
for opportunity if you that's true you
can just say someone's a mean man
doesn't have to be a mean black man or a
mean white man
no i agree i i think that's
i kind of
i kind of but the debate is about racism
so it's going to get dragged in so
that's what they always do to me when
they're losing the argument about gender
because i don't really argue race too
much on my show like if i argue stuff
it's usually more gender based right and
whenever
the girls that i'm arguing against are
losing the conversation like when i when
i argue against feminism they'll just go
to well you're a white woman and i'm
just like
it's the go-to isn't it i'm just like
could you could you offer me something
of substance like an argument not just i
mean yeah
i'm pretty pale
yeah we also have to understand that
most people have been taught
that debate
is wrong
so it's like oh if you haven't if you've
got a bad opinion just keep it to
yourself yeah that's what we've been
told well and if and if i'm wrong like
if i'm wrong or they're wrong like you
should want to debate ideas like you
learn a lot like my opinions have
changed on certain things because of
debates i've had so am i yeah and it's
like if nobody talks to each other we're
afraid of like offending the other
person like we can't get to the truth
you have to you have to be willing to
risk offending people yeah even this
video here is probably going to offend
some people do you know what i mean
but you have to be able to risk
offending people yeah no one of our
great presidents said if you start a man
in a race a hundred years behind it is
awfully difficult to catch up so i don't
think jordan peterson is suffering from
anything except an exaggerated sense of
entitlement and resentment and his own
privilege is invisible to him and it's
manifest with lethal intensity and
ferocity right here on stage
jordan i'm going to have to let you
respond to that
[Music]
well
what i derived from that series of
rebuttals let's say is twofold the first
is that
saying that the radical left goes too
far when they engage in violence is not
a sufficient response by any stretch of
the imagination because there are sets
of ideas in radical leftist thinking
that led to the catastrophes of the 20th
century and that was at the level of
idea not at the level of violent action
it's a very straightforward thing to say
you're against violence it's like being
against poverty it's like you know
generically speaking decent people are
against
poverty and violence doesn't address the
issue in the least
and with regards to
my privilege or lack thereof i mean i'm
not making the case that i haven't had
advantages in my life and disadvantages
in my life like most people you don't
know anything about my background or
where i came from but it doesn't matter
to you because fundamentally i'm a mean
white man that's a hell of a thing to
say in a debate
[Applause]
[Music]
let me let me just say very very brief
because i want to move on to men and
women
the mean mad white comment was not
historical excavation of your past it's
based upon the evidence vitriol with
which you speak in the denial of a sense
of equanimity among combatants in an
argument so i'm saying again you're a
mean mad white man and the viciousness
is evident okay
so i have a question do you think
there's money in racism there's money in
everything no capitalism sometimes i
think these people shoot
like sometimes i think these people
like him like i don't i don't know him i
like race hustlers yeah like they almost
do it for because okay for example
me i know if you say certain words on
the channel you get more views
there's like a particular audience like
like because i used to post more like
random stuff and my channel started to
blow up when i like stopped doing that
right and it was more talking about like
the problems of men and and there are a
lot of problems again and like stuff
that i really advocate for but sometimes
i think there are people that milk a
problem in order to make money off of
course that's what blm done yeah
that's what b m done it's like
racism sells to a particular demographic
just like feminism